hi everybody I'm Jonathan trance and
today I have a very exciting exhibition
match that we'll be using to decide a
norm tournament coming up here in
November the 2016 st. Louis autumn
invitational will begin from november
seventeenth to the 22nd and i'm joined
here with chief arbiter mike comer will
be doing an excellent job directing the
tournament and i'm also joined by two
very special club members who will be
playing in an exhibition match to decide
who gets which lot number my comer will
go and explain a little bit more of that
to us and then we'll explain a very
special game that these two will be
playing Mike can you tell us a little
more sure Jonathan thank you very much
so a James IV and Mario Roper everybody
remembers Mario all right they'll be
playing a game of losers chess when a
piece is taken we will see if there's a
number underneath that piece and then
that will determine the lot number of
whoever's up all right all right it
sounds really good are you guys ready to
get this thing going I'm ready all right
have you guys ever played giveaway chest
before this would be my very first time
and what about you Mario I played it but
probably on accident by a good chess
player bro you accidentally gave away
all your pieces one time okay well we're
we're gonna go ahead and get this game
going and we'll see what happens okay
we're ready to get this game going Mario
you have the white pieces in this game
so go ahead and make your first move and
I just repeat this is giveaway chess or
lose your chest make your move go ahead
so if you can capture a piece you do
have to capture it up first oh no no ask
me capture no make your move make your
move make your move okay course for the
GM norm is can a pan and Brooks for the
IM section alright first piece has been
captured show the camera nothing under
there okay so just get it off the board
so we still don't know the pairings for
these two gentlemen if you can if you
can capture something you have to take
it yeah all right nothing nothing okay
we're still waiting
all right please change any piece you
one all right show it to the oh yeah you
take okay right okay that's why we'll
figure this out we'll figure this out
nothing again okay this is just a hint
it's gonna be number seven number seven
we got number 70 canopen and Brooks are
pairing number seven okay who's up next
Mike we got for the GM norms we got
cereal pencil and kyboot ski all right
this is very exciting okay it's your
your turn James okay excellent strategy
can you take what can you take ok now
this piece will look at all right show
the camera nothing okay so we're still
waiting so most of these species are not
going to have anything under them yeah
but when they get cash has not been
captured that piece has not been
captured okay Mario if you can capture
something you got to do it it looks like
you have one capture and just think it's
gonna be number four number four how did
I know how did I know who's up next all
right he's a fan favorite in the GM norm
section bamf angle and in the IM section
we got Vitaly nemer all right very
exciting second I am door locks Chuck
again so here and there is no check-in
in loser chess here Kings just another
piece but ok that's his move that's as
Louise it's gonna go for checkmate you
gotta go all right there's no checkmate
a loser go ahead make your move Mario
Kings just another piece
nothing nothing further Bishop I'd you
have to take the James you have no
choice I show that queen the queen is
empty all right so been fine gold is
still on the move okay you gotta take
something it's taking the room Oh
interesting interesting strategy okay we
got no but bangles gonna hate you Wow
especially if that Kings got a low
number man all right and what else who
do we got next we have in the audience
international master Oxshott Chandra and
in the IM section we have Joshua Louis
all right go ahead fellas oh he's daring
them to take that night he's daring on
the take it what you gonna do Mario what
you gonna do yeah yeah very important
this is very important to people in the
audience here under it it does not it
does not make sure to show up shot last
so evilman suspense longer not as that
Bishop got something see more to great
number for raksha chandra aaron number
two that means he's gonna get five
whites in the event all right yeah very
excited he's very excited yeah so that
was a huge [ __ ] shot next up we got a GM
ashwin chair awam in the GM norm and in
the IM norm section a local favorite
probably the highest rated kid out of
st. Louis Matthew Larson his rating has
gone up a ton lately let's see go ahead
make your move
three pretty weak pretty weak oh but you
know you're gonna have to take it right
back oh oh it's a tough game right it's
a tough game wait you win Chuck nothing
okay not another all right nothing again
still waiting nothing all right go ahead
you bring it up bring it up all right
James has a great move let's see if he
sees it uh-oh there you go gotta take it
and with check kind of nothing nothing
to see here so we r ashwin Cherwell and
Matt Larsen are still under good no
check in this column no kicking today
alright a simple pond move but is it
that simple that could be that could be
fatal if Mario knows what he's up to and
what's that what do these two players
playing here for they're playing for a
very special prize here yes on November
twelfth will be having an eighteen
hundred dollar tournament during the
showdown in st. Louis it'll be called
the Saturday night special look at Mario
yeah i guess i guess you can castle I
guess you can castle oh my god yeah it's
not to be at eighteen hundred dollar
prize for very special take the kid or
something else you know a fine yeah I
think you psyched him out Mike yeah yeah
that would say this could affect you got
show the camera oh look at that yeah
just catch that look at you guys who
captures Mario yeah okay he agrees he
agrees okay we're figuring it out for
finger now it takes the rook I'm so all
right nothing nothing nothing big
alright so there's a lot of numbers
under these last few pieces here so
James has a capture yeah he's got it ah
yes I yeah backfire tactical backfire
lose your chest nothing all right wow
these must be a lot of numbers under all
the rest of these here said suspense is
building all right let's go is he gonna
castle all right Oh Mario horrible now
you got all right get right back oh my
god number 949 yeah you can see where
the line is under their number nine who
we got next so Ashwin and Larson both
got number nine and we got on the
Canadian listen and uh Seth Houma that's
my expression of the Canadian hope you
like it okay let's go hopefully it's a
high number
all right he got a he got a good number
all right and for the GM Norv Turner we
got Tanya and angelo young from Chicago
all right let's see what's up all right
some fair Oh Darren him to take it I
forcing him to take it all right what's
under the king nothing up all right
let's see what we got yeah we did have a
another club staff pick all of these
numbers so even Mike and I we got no
idea what's under any of these numbers
here we'll have a number you got number
6 over 6 excellent next up we have a
tulia shuddhi in the GM norm tournament
and then a girish angkor and i am we
still got that number one spot somewhere
in one of these numbers here okay very
strategic Mario needs a lot of help yeah
you running out of pieces here running
out of pieces he's purposely gonna
stalemate them Oh No Oh over this game
is officially over James IV is the
winner yeah all right James you get to
play in the first-ever Saturday night
special how does it feel to play such a
such a competitor how do you feel about
your skills I'm very excited some
different because I usually like to use
corner phrase the herb move is in effect
but I was kind of kind of lost today you
didn't feel as confident in the game you
didn't know as well but it's not the fun
I like this all right and thank you as
well Mario do you have any final words
for us have fun when you play chess have
fun when you play chess in just a minute
we'll figure out how we're going to do
the rest of these pairings I guess see
if I will do it I guess I Mario is your
move next so go ahead just pick up any
piece you want here let's get some let's
get some numbers here all right anything
yep anything under there all right we
got number three right there all right
next up is a woman's US Champion
nazi and in the eye norms tournament
lephone who are all right James pick up
any piece you like let's see if we've
got a number under any of these let's
see anything under there nope all right
Mario grab a piece any peace all right
the king ah number eight number eight
show the camera all right so let's see
if we can figure out the last number all
right it's gotta be number one I'd then
yeah let's see if we can find it all
right look try the rook you can see a
little bit of tape all right yeah the
apps are the final seed of Abraham Ian
and dog ecker all right thank you guys
for watching we look forward to this
norm tournament we wish all the best to
all of the participants if you know if
you're getting excited for this go ahead
and hit like share subscribe and I will
see you guys in November but I got a
question yeah what's up you going with
right yeah sure okay to the damn eight
but this was the sea
you